mm I love days where I don't have to
work and I can just run errands and look
like trash no I'm not even wearing
underwear yeah me neither
I mean I'm not seeing anybody I know so
why would I I actually probably showed
my dick always pops out of these pants
oh I hate walking around with toilet
paper it's so embarrassing why everyone
knows you have a butthole and poop comes
out of it right you're okay
see she agrees hey Dave huh not sure
that's about your butthole but I mean I
guess kind of wait what is going on hey
you're the guy from that video
oh no sorry I don't think so yeah the
little kids music video about his gay
brother what
oh um care look at this I think I found
what they're talking about
[Music]
my brother's brave my brother's wise my
brother doesn't like girls he likes guys
he kisses men that turns a mine and if
you think that's gross well then I think
you're wrong
cuz I think it's cool
my brother's gay that's okay
but I love
in every way my brother
he is gay and that's okay
that's okay what
you